PROFESSOR: OK.
Hi.
I thought I'd give a short
lecture about how logarithms
are actually used.
So a little bit practical.
And also, it naturally
comes in, how quickly
do functions grow?
Which functions grow
faster than others?
And I made a list of a bunch
of functions that
we see all the time.
Linear growth.
Just, the function goes up
along the straight line.
Proportional to x, linear could
have been a c times x,
still linear.
Here that's called polynomial
growth, like some power of x.
Here is faster growth.
We introduced e to the x, and
I'll take this chance to bring
in 2 to the x and 10 to the x.
Especially 10 to the x, because
that'll lead us to
logarithms to base 10, and those
are handy in practice.
So that's exponential growth.
And here are some that
grow faster still.
x factorial, n factorial grows
really fast. And n to the nth
or x to the xth is a function
that grows still faster.
And of course, we could
cook up a function the
grew faster than that.
X to the x to the x power would
really just take off.
And we could find functions
that grow more slowly.
But let's just take these
and let x be 1000.
Just to have a kind of realistic
idea of how these
compare when x is 1000.
OK.
So I'm skipping to c.
So x will be 1000.
10 cubed.
Let me just write
it as 10 cubed.
So x is going to be 1000.
And because these are big
numbers, I'm going to write
them as powers of 10.
OK.
so how about 1000 squared?
10 cubed squared will
be 10 to the sixth.
1000 cubed, we're up
to 10 to the ninth.
And onwards.
Like, this is where the
economists are working.
The national debt is
in this range.
OK.
Now fortunately, it's
not in this range.
2 to the thousandth power.
And if I want to be able to
compare it, I'll write that
approximately as 10 to--
well, if it's 2 to the
thousandth power, it'll be 10
to a smaller power.
And 300 is pretty close for
2 to the thousandth.
Then e to the thousandth, that's
going to be bigger than
2. e is 2.7 et cetera.
This is more like 10 to the--
I think this is right--
about 434, maybe.
And 10 to the thousandth--
well, I can write
that right in.
10 to the thousandth
when x is 1000.
OK.
So that's the one that
is exactly right.
And also, I could write in 1000
to the thousandth power.
What power of 10 will this be?
10 to the what?
1000 to the thousandth power,
I think, is 10 to the three
thousandth.
Why do I think that?
Because 1000 itself is
10 times 10 times 10.
Three of them, right?
And then we do that 1000 times,
so we have a string of
3000 10s multiplying
each other.
And that's what 10 to the
three thousandth is.
And you might wonder about
a thousand factorial.
Let me make the rough
estimate.
A big number in factorial,
order of magnitude, is
something like, it doesn't grow
as fast as this, because
this is x times x minus
1 times x minus 2.
1000 times 999 times 998.
So we're not repeating
1000 every time.
And the difference--
it turns out that this number
divided by this number, x to
the x over e to the
x, is the right
general picture for factorial.
So that would be, if I divide 10
to the 3000 by 10 and this
power, what do I do?
In a division, I do a
subtraction of exponents,
because I have that many fewer
10s multiplying each other.
So I think it would be 3000,
but I don't want the full
3000, because I take away e to
the thousandth, 434 of them.
So that's about--
2566 is close enough, anyway.
OK.
Giant numbers.
And of course you saw that I
didn't write it out with 1 and
3000, or whatever, zeros.
Hopeless.
OK.
In other words, it's the
exponent that gives me
something I can really
work with.
And the exponent is
the logarithm.
That's what logarithms are.
They are the exponents.
And when they're the exponent
with a 10, I call 10 the base.
And I'm speaking about
logarithms to the base 10.
Can I just copy those
numbers again?
And then I want to write their
logarithms. Because it's the
logarithms that kind of remain
reasonable-looking numbers but
tell you very nicely what's
growing fast.
So let me write out again.
10 cubed, 10 sixth, 10 to the
ninth is polynomial growth
starting with the first power.
Then I'll write down 10 to
the three hundredth,
approximately.
10 to the 434, I think,
is about right.
And then 10 to the 1000.
And then I had 10 to the 2566
as something, roughly 1000
factorial, and then
10 to the 3000.
OK.
I just copied those
numbers again.
And now I plan to take their
logarithms. I can see what's
happening with logarithms.
The logarithm of 10
to the ninth is--
if the base is 10--
the logarithm of 10 to the
ninth is the nine.
This has logarithm 6.
This has logarithm 3.
So you see--
well.
If we took the logarithm of the
national debt, it wouldn't
look too serious.
It would just be up around
9 moving toward 10.
But what I'm using it for
here is to get some
reasonable way to see--
300.
Of course, that's big.
For a logarithm, that's
a very big number.
434, 1000.
These are climbing up.
2566 and 3000.
OK.
So these are the logs.
Just to repeat.
If I wanted this growth, this
list of functions by how fast
they grow, where would
log x appear
in my list of functions?
It would be way at
the left end.
Slower than x.
Much slower than x.
Log x grows very slowly,
as we see here.
And then if you wanted one that
really grew slowly, it
would be log of log x.
That creeps along.
Eventually gets to--
passes any number.
But x has to be enormous.
And one more little comment
before I begin to use some
things graphically.
Because that's the other part
of this talk, is log--
the graphs.
Using logarithms in graphs.
A little point.
You might ask, what about
functions that decay?
What would be the corresponding
functions here
that decay?
Let me write them here.
Decay.
By that I mean, headed
for 0 instead
of headed for infinity.
Well, 1 over x, 1 over x
squared, 1 over x cubed.
Those functions go to
0 faster and faster.
Now, what about these?
The next list would
be 1 over--
I'm dividing, but 1
over 2 to the x.
1 over e to the x.
Can I write that in
a better way?
e to the minus x.
1 over 10 to the x.
Those are going to
0 like crazy.
And of course, if I keep
going, even worse.
So like, x to the minus x power
would be really small.
So my point is just that we
have a scale here that not
only gives us a handle of how
to deal with things that are
growing very fast, but also
things that are going to 0
very fast. The other, the
negative logarithms. The
logarithms of these things would
be minus 3, minus 6,
minus 9 and so on, if
I divide by one.
Good.
All right.
So that suggests the idea.
Now I want to introduce the
idea of a log scale.
So I'm just going to think of
a usual straight line, on
which we usually mark out 0,
1, 2, 3, minus 1, minus 2.
But on this log scale, the
center point, the 0, I'm
really graphing the logarithm
of x instead of x.
That's the point.
That in this log scale,
what I'm picturing
along here will be--
this number will be 10 to
the 0 power, which is 1.
The next one will be 10.
The next one will be 100.
The next one will be 1000.
So you see, within
this picture--
on a graph that we could
draw and look at
on a printed page--
we can get big numbers by going
from the ordinary 1, 2,
3 scale to the log scale, which
puts these points in
this order.
And let me put some
of the other ones.
Now, what one point
goes there?
1/10.
Every time I go that far,
I'm multiplying by 10.
When I go this way, I'm
dividing by 10.
Up there, this is the number
1/10, which is the same as 10
to the minus 1 power, right?
Here is one hundredth.
Here is one thousandth.
And so on.
So this log scale is able to
deal with very small numbers
and very large numbers
in a reasonable way.
And everybody sees the point
here that really, what it is
is the logarithms.
So this is 0.
This is 1, 2, 3, and so on.
Minus 1, minus 2, minus 3.
If I'm graphing, really, these
are the logarithms of x.
And I'm doing logs to base 10
again, because that gives us
nice numbers.
OK.
By the way, what's
that number?
What's that number, halfway
between there and there?
It's not halfway between 1 and
10 in the ordinary sense,
which is whatever,
5 and a half.
No way.
Halfway between here is--
you know what it will be?
It'll be square root of 10.
10 to the 1/2 power.
The half is here.
The log is a half, so
the number is the
square root of 10.
That's about 3, a little
more than 3.
And what would be here, would
be 10 to the minus 1/2.
1 over square root of 10.
So you see that picture.
Oh, I have another question,
before I use the scales.
What if I like the powers
of 2 better?
In many cases, we might
prefer powers of 2.
Well, if I plotted
the numbers--
I'm looking at this log scale.
And suppose I plot the numbers
1, 2, 4, 8, whatever.
16.
What could you tell
me about those?
Well, I know where 1 is.
It's right there.
That's a 1.
Well, two would be a little
further over.
Then 4, then 8 would come
before 10, and 16
would come after 10.
I pointed there, but 16
would not come there.
16 would be a lot closer,
I think, in here.
What's the deal with 1, 2, 4,
8, 16 on this log scale?
They would be equally spaced.
Of course, the spacing would be
smaller than the 10 spacing.
If every time I multiplied by
2, I go the same distance.
After I'd done it
about 10 times--
multiplied by 2 10 times-- so
that's 2 to the tenth power is
close to 1000.
So 10 powers of 2 would bring
me pretty near there.
Anyway.
And here's one more question.
Where is 0?
If my value that I wanted to
plot happened to be 0, where
is it on this graph?
It's not there.
You can't plot 0
on a log scale.
It's way down at the--
you know, it's at the minus
infinity end of the graph.
Infinity is up there at that
end, and 0 is down here.
OK.
Good.
So can we use that log scale?
How do we use that log scale?
Let me give you an idea
for what use that
log scale might be.
Practical use.
Suppose I know, or have reason
to believe, that my function
might be of the form y is
something times x to the nth.
I have some quantity y.
The output when the
input is x.
But I don't know these,
that number a.
So I've done an experiment.
And I would like to know
what is a, and
especially, what is n?
I would like to know how the
growth is progressing.
And I'm just taking simple
growth law here.
OK.
I would graph it.
I'd get a bunch of points, I
put them on a graph, and I
look at the graph.
Now if I just graph these
things, if I just graph that
y, here is x and here's
y, suppose n is 1.5.
Suppose my growth rate,
and this is very
possible, is x to the 1.5.
And a is some number--
who knows.
Could even be 1.
Suppose a was 1.
So then I'm graphing
y as x to the 1.5.
What does that look like?
Well, it looks like that.
The problem is that if
the real growth--
the real good relation--
see, I would have a few
points that might be
close to that curve.
But if I'm looking that curve,
I frankly could not tell 1.5
from 1.6 growth rate.
The truth is, I couldn't
tell it from 2.
I couldn't tell what the actual
growth rate is from my
graph, which has a little error,
so I'm not too sure.
And the point is x to the 1.5
and x to the 2 would be all--
If I sketch the graph, it
would look like that.
But go to the log scale.
Go to a log log graph.
So I'm going to take logs
of both sides, and
look and plot that.
So I take the logs of both
sides, so I take the log of my
outputs y, and now this is a
product of that times that.
What's the rule for
logarithms?
Add logarithms. So this
would be log a plus
log of x to the nth.
But now what's the log
of x to the nth?
Beautiful again.
This is x times x
times x n times.
At least of n is an integer.
Think of it as x multiplied
by itself n times.
When I take the logarithm,
I add n times.
Log of x to the nth
is n log x.
Now that, let me
graph that now.
This is now a log picture.
So I'm graphing log y against
log x, which was the whole
point of my log scale, to
think of doing this.
And what kind of a curve will
I see from this equation on
this graph paper?
A straight line.
That is some constants
plus some slope.
n will be the slope
times the x.
It's like capital Y is capital
A plus n times
capital X or something.
But better for me to
write log, so we
remember what it is.
So on this paper, suppose--
I did the example
x to the 1.5.
OK.
So in this example, a
is 1 and n is 1.5.
So what would my points
look like here?
Now remember, I should really
allow negative logarithms.
Because this is the
point, right?
This is x equals 1 here.
The log is 0, but
the number is 1.
Ha, OK.
So when the log is 0, you
see, it's going to
be a straight line.
And actually, when I took a to
be 1, its logarithm will be 0.
The line would go right
through there.
It would have a slope
of 1 and 1/2.
My points will be really
close to line.
I measure out, if I go out a
distance 1, then I go up a
distance 1.5.
Right?
Up 1.5.
When I go across by 1 on
the log picture, it
could be down here.
My numbers could be
smaller or larger.
A straight line.
I can get out a ruler and
estimate the slope far more
accurately than I could hear
with a lot more software.
OK.
So that's an important, very
important instance in which we
wonder what the rate of
growth is, and the
graph shows it to us.
But just make a little point
that I've put some points
here, like near a line, and
that raises another graph
question of very great
importance.
Suppose you have some
experiments that put points
close to a line, but not
right on a line.
You want to fit a line
close to them.
You want to fit the best line
to the experimental points.
How do you fit a
straight line?
That's an important thing.
And let me save that for a
future chance, because I want
to tell you about it.
The best, the standard
way is what's
called the least squares.
So least squares is a very
important application.
And the best line, it turns out,
is a calculus problem.
So for the moment let's
pretend they're
right on the line.
Its slope, which we easily find,
tells us this number.
May I mention one
other behavior?
So another possibility.
If y is not growing
polynomially, but suppose y is
growing exponentially--
I'll just put it here,
because it's not
going to be a big deal.
y is some--
call it b, e to the c x.
So that's a different
type of growth.
That's the big part of the
today's lecture, is to say,
this is a quite different
growth.
But it would be equally hard--
or even harder--
to find this growth rate c
from an ordinary graph.
The graph would take off even
faster than this one.
You couldn't see what's
happening.
The good idea is, take
logarithms. But what do we
want to do?
We'll take the logarithm
of y--
log y, as before--
will be the log of B plus
the log of e to the cx.
Oh, maybe I should have made
this 10 to the cx, just to
make it all--
instead of the e, I
could use the 10.
Whatever.
Because I've been talking about
logarithms to the base
10, so let me use the
powers of 10 here.
What's the logarithm
of 10 to the cx?
When the base is 10, the
logarithm is the exponent.
c times x.
So what am I seeing
in this equation?
That's an equation when I've
taken logarithms, my big
numbers become reasonable.
And also, very small numbers
become reasonable.
And I get a straight
line again.
I get a straight line.
But it's not in this
log paper.
The logarithm of y, the y-axis,
the vertical axis, is
still log scale.
But you see it's ordinary
x there now.
So I don't use log
x for this one.
Just ordinary x.
It's semi log paper.
Logarithm in the in the vertical
direction, ordinary
in the x direction.
OK.
Good.
Now I just want to add
one sort of example.
Because it's quite important
and also quite practical.
May I tell you about--
Let me ask you the question,
and see if you get an idea.
Because this is like
basic to calculus.
Let me talk about--
this e will stand for error.
Error e.
And what error am
I talking about?
I'm talking about the error as
the difference between the
derivative--
I have some function f of x.
And there's its derivative.
And I compare that with
delta f over delta x.
So what do I know?
I know that as this is a
function of delta x, I'm
comparing the instant slope
versus the average slope over
a distance delta x.
So it's not 0, right?
This one is a finite movement.
Delta x produces a finite
moment delta f.
As delta x goes to 0, that
does approach this.
So here's my question.
My question is, this is
approximately some constant
times delta x to some power.
And my question is, what is n?
How close?
What's a rough estimate of how
near the delta f over delta x
is to the actual derivative?
OK.
So I have to tell you what I
meant by delta f over delta x.
I meant what you also meant, f
at x plus delta x minus f at x
divided by delta x.
In other words, that's
the familiar delta f.
Moving forward from x, I would
call that a forward
difference, a forward delta f.
Because I'm starting at x, and
I think of delta x as moving
me a little bit forward.
So I get the delta f, I divide
by the delta x, and that's
what this thing means.
And do you know what n is?
Let me connect it
to my pictures.
If I tried to graph this,
I'd have a graph.
You know.
Here's my delta x
and here's my e.
This difference says delta x
goes to 0, it goes to 0.
You know, if delta x is
small, e is small.
If I divide delta x by 10,
e divides by something.
I don't even know if you
see it on the camera.
The graph has gone into a--
well, a black hole, or
a chalk hole, or a
white hole, or something.
It's just completely
invisible.
I can't see the slope
of this thing.
But if I did it on log log
paper, I'd see it clearly.
And the answer would be 1.
The error, the difference
between derivative and average
slope, goes like delta
x to the first power.
And then we can see later where
that 1 comes from, and
we can see where that a is.
It's all in Taylor series.
But here's my practical point.
There is a much better delta
f than this one.
A much better delta
f over delta x.
An average slope that's much
more accurate, and that in
calculation I would
always use.
And the trouble with this
one is, it's lopsided.
It's one-sided.
I only went forward.
Or if delta x is negative,
I'm only going backwards.
And it turns out that the
average of forward and
backward is like centered
at difference.
So let me tell you a center
difference. f at
x plus delta x.
So look a little forward, but
take the difference from
looking a little backward.
That would be my change in f.
But now what do I divide by
to get a reasonable slope?
Well, this is the change in f
going from minus delta x--
delta x to the left of the point
to delta x to the right
of the point.
The real movement there in
the x-axis was a movement
of two delta xs.
So I would call this a
center difference.
Can I write that word
"centered" down?
And if I use that, which is a
lot smarter if I'm practically
wanting to get pictures,
then what happens?
So if this is now instead of
this, instead of choosing this
lopsided, simple, familiar but
not that great difference, if
I go for this one, the answer
is, n changes to 2.
n is 2 for this one.
The accuracy is way, way better
for center differences.
And the point about the log
graphs is, if I plot those
points on the graph I would see
that slope of 2 in the log
log graph, it would be again--
in ordinary graph, it would
become invisible
as delta x got small.
But on a log scale, I'd
see it perfectly.
OK.
Some practical uses of
logarithms. Now that we no
longer use slide rules,
this is what we do.
Thanks.
NARRATOR: This has been
a production of MIT
OpenCourseWare and
Gilbert Strang.
Funding for this video was
provided by the Lord
Foundation.
To help OCW continue to provide
free and open access
to MIT courses, please
make a donation at
ocw.mit.edu/donate.